arnaud montebourg le ministre du
redressement productif a endossé à la
veste de travail de renault lors de sa
visite ce mardi 28 mai de lusine flins
dans les yvelines carlos ghosn le pdg de
la marque au losange qui l'accompagnait
a précisé que le marché de l'automobile
resteraient difficiles durant les
prochaines années
même si des embauches sont prévues les
précisions d'anthony rêche et de
jonathan vilma les salariés de l'usiné
renault de flins ont enfin entendu une
bonne nouvelle ce mardi midi lors de la
visite du ministre du redressement
productif
arnaud montebourg la production de la
nouvelle nissan micra dans les yvelines
dès 2016 mis en place par l'accord de
compétitivité début mars permettra à
priori d'embaucher de nouveaux salariés
alors en ce qui concerne l'emploi 82
mille voitures en plus sur l' usine
c'est à peu près je dirais autour d'un
millier d'emplois bon alors est-ce qu'il
y aura des embauches ou pas ça dépend
comment lusine s'organise ça dépend
comment le marché européen va évoluer ça
dépend de d2 lui succéder bande de
jouets se ça dépend de beaucoup de
choses
vu l'état actuel du marché de
l'automobile des embauches futures ne
sont pas encore possible
carlos ghosn reste évasif sur le nombre
de recrutements qui seront également
conditionnée aux ventes des clio iii et
iv et de la zoé
de son côté arnaud montebourg en tenue
de travail pour l'occasion a martelé le
retour de la production industrielle sur
le territoire aujourd'hui la direction
de renault de l'alliance renault nissan
tient ses engagements et relocalise sur
le territoire français
des dizaines de milliers de véhicules
donc c'est un renforcement de la base
industrielle france et c'est le retour
de renault vers le made in france
nissan produit à l'heure actuelle ce
modèle en inde pour l'exporter en europe
avec la fabrication du modèle japonais
l'usiné de flins dans les yvelines sera
le 1er site français a semblé un de ses
véhicules et à l'occasion de ce
déplacement du ministre est alors que la
situation dans l'automobile reste vous
le savez compliqué nous en avons profité
pour demander à quelques salariés de
flins s'ils craignaient pour leur emploi
voici quelques réponses
combien déjà promis qu'elle
il ya du boulot bah ça me soulage en
paix pour l'instant on a un avenir
incertain encore c'est rien n'est
garanti
déjà nous ont déjà annoncé c'est vrai
que c'est une bonne nouvelle ils vont
ans et qui aurait 82000 nissan micra est
ici à fin mai c'est qu'en 2016 d'ici là
il y aura
il y aura beaucoup de changements on est
un peu inquiet parce que quand tu es à
la compétitivité est si bien il ya du
boulot derrière mais c'est qu'il nous
faut il ya mc effectif en manque
d'effectif et après qu'est ce qui se
passe après il y aura quoi en 2016
qu'est ce qui nous garantit qui est de
l'avenir encore qui a rien n'y a aucune
garantie aujourd'hui aucune bombe ainsi
à croquer l'activité